Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to immerse ourselves into
a wonderful art of rigid body disentanglement,
or in simpler words, we are going to solve
these puzzles!
To be more exact, we’ll sit and enjoy our
time while a learning-based algorithm is going
to miraculously solve some really challenging
puzzles.
Yes, this is going to be a spicy paper.
Now, these puzzles are roughly ordered by
difficulty, where the easier ones are on the
left, and as we traverse to the right, things
get more and more difficult.
And get this, this new technique is able to
algorithmically solve all of them.
If you are like me and you don’t believe
a word of what’s been said, let’s see
if it lives up to its promise by solving three
of them, in increasing difficulty.
Let’s start with an easy one.
Example number one.
Here, the algorithm recognizes that we need
to pull the circular part of the red piece
through the blue one and apply the appropriate
rotations to make sure that we don’t get
stuck during this process.
While we finish this sequence, please note
that this video contains spoilers for some
well-known puzzles.
If you wish to experience them yourself, pause
this video, and, I guess, buy and try them.
This one was good enough to warm ourselves
up, so let’s hop on to the next one.
Example number two, the duet puzzle.
Well that was quite a bit of a jump in difficulty
because we seem stuck right at the start.
Hmm… this seems flat out impossible…until
the algorithm recognizes that there are these
small notches in the puzzle, and if we rotate
the red piece correctly, we may go from one
cell to the next one.
Great, so now it’s not impossible anymore,
it is more like a maze that we have to climb
through.
But the challenges are still not over.
Where is the endpoint?
How do we finish this puzzle?
There has to be a notch on the side…yes,
there is this one or this one, so we ultimately
have to end up in one of these places…and,
there we go.
Bravo!
Experiment number three.
My favorite, the enigma.
Hmm..this is exactly the opposite of the previous
one.
It looks so easy!
Just get the tiny opening of the red piece
onto this part of the blue one, and we are
done.
Uh-oh.
The curved part is in the way.
Something that seemed so easy now suddenly
seems absolutely impossible!
But fortunately, this learning algorithm does
not get discouraged, and does not know what
impossible is, and it finds this tricky series
of rotations to go around the entirety of
the blue piece, and then, finish the puzzle.
Glorious.
What a rollercoaster!
A hallmark of an expertly designed puzzle.
And to experience more of these puzzles, make
sure to have a look paper and its website
with a super fun interactive app.
If you do, you will also learn really cool
new things…for instance, if you get back
home in the middle of the night after a long
day, and two of your keys are stuck together,
you will know exactly how to handle it.
And all this can be done through the power
of machine learning and computer graphics
research.
What a time to be alive!
So how does this wizardry work exactly?
The key techniques here are tunnel discovery
and path planning.
First, a neural network looks at the puzzle
and identifies where the gaps and notches
are, and specifies the starting position and
the goal position that we need to achieve
to finish the puzzle.
Then, a set of collision-free key configurations
are identified, after which, the blooming
step can commence.
So what does that do?
Well, the goal is to be able to go through
these narrow tunnels that represent tricky
steps in the puzzles that typically require
some unintuitive rotations.
These are typically the most challenging parts
of the puzzles, and the blooming step starts
from these narrow tunnels and helps us reach
the bigger bubbles of the puzzle.
But as you see, not all roads connect, or
at least, not easily.
The forest connect step tries to connect these
roads through collision-free paths, and now,
finally, all we have to do is find the shortest
path from the start to the endpoint to solve
the puzzle.
And also, according to my internal numbering
system, this is Two Minute Papers episode
number 478.
And to every single one of you Fellow Scholars
who are watching this, thank you so much to
all of you for being with us for so long on
this incredible journey.
Man, I love my job, and I jump out of bed
full of energy and joy knowing that I get
to read research papers and flip out together
with many of you Fellow Scholars on a regular
basis.
Thank you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!